you feel me sometimes you got to put
your hands on the [ __ ] and let the
[ __ ] know
that you ain't gonna play with it yeah
you know what i'm saying cause
we all out here taking penalty chances
for this [ __ ] you gotta pay me to look
at this man
you gotta pay me you know what i'm
saying in jail so if that's what we're
gonna do and that's the role
that that's that's like more than a 50
chance of the road
then yeah it's gonna play you feel me
you're gonna have to put your hands on
it
so it's like
the best things to do is to have you a
white [ __ ] if you have you a white
[ __ ]
or an asian [ __ ] she a [ __ ] that's not
black
if you have your [ __ ] that's not black
i promise you you ain't gonna have to
put your hands on her and she's gonna
bring you a little bit more money
you know what i'm saying when you're
dealing with black [ __ ]
african-americans you know what i'm
saying you're gonna have to put your
hands on you intimidate them
and that's just because where we come
from you feel me it's like
and due to the circumstances and
situations that i'm pimping you home
i know you're a real [ __ ] and you know
i'm a real [ __ ] so some [ __ ]
some [ __ ] a black man ain't gonna be
some [ __ ] a black man
can't tell no black [ __ ] you feel me
like when
you you could tell the white [ __ ] like
look go get the blade with no shoes on
[ __ ] you [ __ ] up
give me your shoes what do you guys
think of that
that's a new era that's a gorilla pimp
that's some other [ __ ]
that's a gorilla that's just that's it
that's the game
yeah i mean that's i mean you know
that's not where i come from
you're gonna have much more class and
style and respect well you know i'm a
gentleman before anything i was raised
by my mother
you know what i'm saying she didn't
teach me to you know physically abuse
people because that sounds like abuse to
me
now don't get me wrong when somebody get
online you may have to
you know do something but not like that
to me
yeah to me i don't know about him
what do you make of that dc it's just
it was all over the place to be honest
you know the game
well he was all over the place because
he was swiggling that was almost yeah
but
i mean the relationship i've talked to a
lot of pimps now a lot of girls
that have had pimps and it seems like a
lot of the females
want they seek out of him they want that
relationship it's not like the pimp is
making them do it
they suck out these guys and say hey i
want you to be my pimp
well let me tell you since beginning of
time a lot of women
associate and get hit with love
so that would be that type of woman you
know what i mean because
i can't talk to you and we can't come to
a mutual understanding conversation
you need to go because you can have me
put in jail
and i'm not going to jail for you no
money nothing
so that's why i'm staying with that
and that's just me thank you
all right gino and dc yeah
you guys you guys grew up where you're
from
l.a i was born and raised here in l.a
yes
in d.c where are you from yeah i like
born and raised
and the neighborhoods you guys grew up
in
was were there pimps when you guys grew
up
you're both older gentlemen so yes i'm
wondering how the game has
has developed and changed over the years
i can speak on me you know
i was brought up in this my father was
in the life
my uncles kind of ran this city of l.a
back in the 60s and the 70s
they were very prominent people so this
was the only thing i knew
i i didn't see nothing else but that i
saw my daddy
and his friends which i considered
called my uncles today
they had the big fancy cars and all that
stuff
and um it inspired me to be in the game
so that's i really what year was this
when you were a teenager
[ __ ] no man i saw this from a kid like
six years old
seven years what year was this 1966
66 yeah we moved to the west side
in 66 i came from the east side
and we moved to the west side in 66
and i went to good schools you know i
didn't have to take this
this this lane that i took i just did it
because
it was what i wanted
so um that's how i really got into it
now like i said that was in 1966.
you know i saw the cadillacs the jewelry
and the
the money the girls i saw that so
you know do you see the role models you
had growing up were similar
well you could say
for the most part you know um
yeah you know i grew up on the same side
of town on the west side
so it was the same thing going on over
there
do you think the the tim prostitute
thing has gone on for
as long as man has been around or oh for
sure yeah
in some form yeah yeah profession so
yeah yeah how has it changed over the
years
oh wait godly i mean
it took a [ __ ] a 180 you know it's
it's not the same today with all this um
new internet stuff and the laws changed
so that makes a uh a lot
different you know much harder yeah it's
like you know
i wouldn't advise nobody to do this
nobody
i mean you know if you want to go to
prison for the rest of their life
i decided one day i was sitting in jail
and i decided i was a bad criminal
so i changed my life i said well if i
get caught
33 times doing all different type of
stuff i'm a
this ain't working for me i'm a bad
criminal so i came home and uh
i changed my life so you're no longer
doing it you're no i'm no longer
in anything illegal you're you're
respectable but i'm still in the light
because the life is life
it's just i'm playing in a different
field there's nothing you're doing
that's that's good no
nothing illegal not nothing like i'm a
i'm a fast designer
um i do events you know what i'm saying
i'm um
i give three big events a year so
it's nothing i do that's illegal but
it's still
the knowledge that i got from coming up
in the life i just use it to what i'm
doing now and the circle of friends
continues
well yes yes because i never want to
forget where i came from
you know i'm going to have love for for
my for my peers that i came up with
you know i'll never say i'm better than
you or
i can't deal with you because i'm you
know whatever
i i don't do that so yeah it's still the
same
and dc same similar story for you you're
now a respectable businessman
yes sir yes i run a restaurant now
i've been in the business for the last
four years simply delicious
southern creole cuisine in mid-city la
okay yeah and um i've been doing income
property for the last
20 years 25 years also
and did your experience in the game
help you guys with what you're doing
today oh for sure me i can't speak on
him but it did with him too
i mean i'm around him a lot i've been
knowing him since he was younger
um we just utilize
what we learned there and put it in a
legitimate form
i mean just look think about it you know
think about all the people that
turn their life around
they were in the game at one point in
time and now they're just not don't do
it
i mean most people my age and i'm 60
years old i just turned 60 last month
he's a little younger but most people
might our age man
he'd be a fool to go out here and try to
do this stuff now
how many how many girls did you have in
your stable back in the day
well i'ma tell you honestly around three
i just had three
dc well i had a string at one time
but setting them down all at the same
time didn't kind of pan out
so i say about six six five to six
consistently and these are involved
these are african-american girls or
white girls hispanic
it was a mix yeah and
it is
something for everybody yeah and did
ever you know i've heard some stories
and the typical
stereotype of pimps is that there's
intimidation and violence and all that
stuff
is that was that part of your thing well
it's that was there it was a lot of that
i would say because you know a lot of
cats
can't accept the news you know uh
when they when they female chose up on
them you know so some of them
kind of had the cowboy approach like if
you get your heart stolen
you know you might get into a shootout
your violent hits like stealing
someone's horse you know
if they're not straight lace you know
but if they stray lace they understand
how the game goes so it's a violence
was was part of the game back then it
came with the territory
yeah you know in prison also
yeah all that goes with the territory
you know
you know yeah so what was the longest
your girls have stayed with you
any one of them like what's the longest
a girl has been with you
man i just had one just leave me after
seven years
i mean and she worked a square job and
stuff but
she was really a good girl you know what
i mean just one day she just woke up and
decided she wanted to be on drugs
you know what i'm saying um
and it so i say seven years
i mean because in in any lifestyle when
you're dealing with women
they come and they go they don't come to
state
i mean they come going so every day i
used to look at this
them girls and say man you guys still
here are y'all crazier to me
you know what i'm saying so
yeah i can say seven years what about
you d yeah i mean
you know seven eight nine i mean yeah
i i had got decent runs you know
five years six years it depended over
the
you know over the decades that i was in
the game
you know each decade had i had my share
of runs
you know were you guys married when you
did this
no no uh i was
you were um
i my ex-wife the mother of my children
who i love dearly and i always would
love
um she understood my lifestyle
and you got to understand when i did
anything
i mean because i just wasn't pimping i
was doing it all you know what i'm
saying that's why i say i was a bad
criminal
because i was getting arrested and it
was like this ain't working you know you
get
you look up one day and even been
arrested 33 times and
you know but she understood my lifestyle
she knew it was all just to make a
better way for us to live
you're supporting the family exactly
and she was accepting you know to a
certain extent as much as a woman can be
what
was the arrangement with the girls do
you keep all of the money
at yes yes what what
when it came to that but sometimes
when they did other things we made deals
you know what i'm saying because it just
wasn't about
that with me you know understand it was
we did other things we did jewelry we
did it all
so we had to make a deal because you
want everybody to be happy
we want to cut the pie of fair when it
came to other than
you know dealing with this pimp stuff
you know what i'm saying
do you see the same thing you would keep
the money
i would manage the money yeah
and what you provide is security
definitely that came with the territory
and do you guys have children you do you
do i do i got two
children dc no no kids well i have kids
but
you know they're not coming up
throughout the game yeah no but but
let's say one of your daughters or sons
decided to kind of
follow your footsteps and oh i don't
think so
that's not gonna happen you know um
it's funny you say that because i really
feel fortunate because of my era
everybody was doing something illegal
yeah to make money that was the
hip slick cool thing to do but none of
our kids
followed in our footsteps and i think
i would had a generational curse because
i followed in my grandfather's footsteps
and then my father's footsteps and
i'm just thank god every day you know
both my kids are grown they're doing
their own thing they're
legitimate people they pay taxes every
day i mean every year
so you did something right yeah yeah i
mean it's off to the grace of god
nothing i did you know
nothing i did and you would have sex
with your girls
yeah yes
yeah that also came with that part of
the job territory
you know dc did you do prison time
well i got caught up in some stuff but i
don't
want to get into that no problem i won't
i won't push you
what are the qualities you think of pimp
needs to to
to be successful to be a good team be
true to the game
true to yourself and straight lace
with no chase you know you know what i
mean just be straight-laced about
the business yeah gino what do you think
to me
the qualities for a good mac
a man not just a pimp a mac
he has to represent himself as a king
the world has to revolve around him
you're coming into my world i'm not
coming into yours
so you got to be dressed
you gotta you gotta give them something
that they've never seen before
when you walk in the room the whole room
should be looking at me
that's the way i dress that's the way i
feel because i put myself on pedestal
so if i don't feel good about me i'm
gonna feel good about having you
the the pimp style has changed
dramatically over the years ooh
yes hey we watched the video the other
day
and it was like really i mean you know i
was like but
one of the videos on my channel no no
this is a video period
yeah you know about this new wave stuff
i call it new wave
yeah some people call it like gorilla
pimping and stuff like that yeah well
that's been going on since the beginning
of time
so we're not gonna talk about it i'm
just talking about their attire
oh yeah they're the way they represent
their self
um i thank god i'm not
i'm not i'm not into this today you know
because i couldn't do it i mean the
skinny jeans and
the real you know i guess the rapping
really
you know people they want to be rappers
yeah
well a lot of them come up you know
without no
good background following and then you
know
and um they took all the class out the
game
you know what i mean and they think it's
hip to run around with the urban clothes
on and
and uh with their pants hanging off of
them and when it started changing they
start coming out there with the clothes
two three times too big and big t-shirts
and you know i
it just was a it was a big change
you know and that was in the early 90s
that i could recall when it started
surfacing well really they don't have
morals and principles today anything
goes you know what i mean
they're playing with kids i mean it's
just it's just a whole different thing i
i tell people that recognize me
uh and go another direction don't do
this
we're drugs a part of the picture where
drugs are part of the picture when you
guys are in your heyday
with me yes and your girls no now it's
him
but you were using i've always used yeah
yeah and
and crack was was a huge drama no no
that that came
later on in life okay you know i was
brought up around like i said i was
brought up around the game
cocaine was acceptable back then yeah
you know it was a pimp drug
it was a hustler drug so that's how i
got it and then
elevated to different stuff along the
line like i told you i was down here for
three years
when i came home and forget the wine
guard
you know so you got out of prison they
put you up and yeah they put me there
so that happens a lot yeah yeah they put
me there but i had a house in encino
i had found two girls and they got into
this internet stuff
and they got me rich and they got a
house in this you know and
it just took off from there you know
this life has a lot of ups and downs
the good the bad and ugly if you're
gonna get into it people
accept everything that goes with it
because it's not all peaches and cream i
mean you know
sometimes you know we have to eat cut up
a peanut butter jelly sandwich just to
eat
you know i mean you know it's not what
this cracked up to be
but the blessing part is to live to be
our age
i think and lived throughout the game
you know
successfully passed 30 which most people
don't
you know coming up in the game you know
because of all the
trials and errors that you encounter and
um sometimes it
just be on people and not in them yeah i
mean
exactly so i'm talking about the ism you
know what i mean the game
so yeah a lot of them just have it on
them and it's not in them so
they just go through a fade a fast or
something you know what i mean
and it's not really who they are yeah
it's not cut out for everybody
yeah you know they just slide in the
game off a crack act on a banana peeling
and
think they could do it you know which of
all the women that you had worked for
you which which is your personal
favorite
you know with me i have to love them all
you know uh a certain amount of love
because that comes with the respect that
they give me
as a man so i got to cherish them and um
so all of them had a special part in my
life like recently uh
like this last month a friend of mine
got killed and she was a working girl
um they found her i got a call we had
when
we had went to las vegas on the vacation
me and her
and she wanted to stay with me and i
said no you got to go back to your
family
and you know you got a kid and stuff you
know um
um she gave me a donation but i didn't
do anything with her as far as putting
her out there and then she did all this
other home but i'm not turning down
nothing
as far as somebody giving me a gift
and um i got a call like three sundays
ago one or two sundays three sundays are
gone
they said um uh
so-and-so was found in the motel room
where their
throat slash it really bothered me
because when i put her on that plane
to go back to kansas city she was like
no i want to stay with you and i'm
trying to tell i'm not with the game
i understand this is you but this ain't
me you have a kid
so i just think well i'm not going to
say that
maybe if i were the kempers this
wouldn't happen because
when it's your time to die it's your
time to die i just hated that
it happened to her it really affected me
and i just had to take sit back and uh
think you know thank god that i'm not in
that lifestyle no more
you know where i could have really
pursued her in a way because she really
wanted to
be my girl doing that i'm like i'm 60
years old swear
i'm not doing that today do you think
the
the relationship a woman has with her
pimp
is somehow trying to recreate the
relationship she might have had with her
father
they call you daddy they look up to you
they give you the money they
they bring you you may have be a father
figure to somebody
themselves yeah they was missing that in
their life
you know some of them and they wanted
that and uh needed it
you know and sometimes had abusive
relationships with their fathers and
they
end up with a abusive relationship again
with the tim
not you guys necessarily but in general
well like like i said you got to be
there
everything so that means a father figure
because you're basically guiding these
people
along the way what you want them are
what you put
what you perceive you to be so you can
want the best for them
so yeah kind of sorta
all right you guys very interesting talk
yeah
yeah thank you very much for coming in
and sharing your
your experiences yeah thank you for your
time thanks for
everybody yes thank you very much okay
you